[Music]
hi folks my name is mark Crandall and I
handle global regulatory compliance with
Google cloud a little bit of background
I'm a lawyer by training I'm part of
Google cloud engineering to help ensure
that the products we provide to
customers meet their regulatory
compliance needs as best we can we focus
on three areas the first thing is
working with the sales organization as
well as our legal teams to find out what
the latest trends are from a compliance
perspective and what the market needs we
work with engineering and product
management to drive change within the
organization to help address those needs
and finally we work with regulatory
authorities to help learn what the
trends are from regulators and also get
their input when it comes to building
our services I've been at Google twelve
years and was and as a lawyer helped
launch one of Google clouds first
product offerings G suite in 2006 so
let's move forward so the thing we want
to talk about is how can we manage
regulatory risk and I talked about
managing regulatory risk many folks
operate in regulated markets you might
operate in the healthcare field or in
government or in financial services or
education or you might have privacy
considerations such as the recently the
recently implemented general data
protection regulation gdpr which took
effect in May so a lot of folks have
regulatory compliance considerations so
the question is how to mitigate that
risk now your counsel and your
compliance experts are the folks you
want to look at but we also have
experience in cloud at Google and we'd
like to share some of our experiences so
we're going to talk about four areas
today we're going to talk about the
importance of conducting a compliance
assessment within your own organization
your own vertical we're going to talk
about the importance of transparency
about the services we provide the
importance of contracts and making sure
things are in writing to demonstrate
that to your regulators and then time
permitting we're going to talk about
some regulatory frameworks
have been important we've seen in the
last few years and our work in the cloud
so let's focus first on compliance
assessments so Google operates in
virtually every country not every
country but almost and let's think about
all the industry verticals per country
like health care education government
manufacturing there's potentially
millions of regulatory compliance
combinations worldwide at Google we are
not the expert and every single
compliance framework combination that's
possible our customers in their industry
are the experts in their specific field
you have your council you have your
compliance experts your chief privacy
officers your compliance officers or
security officers so you should leverage
what you know regarding your specific
field and by the way your council really
can help you there what we're saying
here is not legal advice
you have your own lawyers however we at
Google are experts in the cloud and we
are also experts in having provided
cloud services to many customers who are
regulated so we have a lot of experience
in that regard so you can partner with
us the work in the leverage that we have
in the industry with regards to helping
people our experience our capabilities
and the point then is that this is a
shared responsibility you have your
compliance obligations you have your
compliance expertise we have expertise
in the cloud and the ideas that we
provide you with the transparency you
need to be able to conduct a meaningful
risk assessment based on the services we
provide so when I talk about meaningful
risk assessment the key here is to think
like a regulator in all the years that
we've been doing this with regards to
Google cloud there's one thing that's
that's been a common denominator across
all regulated fields that we've seen and
that common denominator is that
regulators expect they expect that you
conduct your due diligence before you
adopt a cloud provider it doesn't matter
if it's the privacy sector in Europe or
healthcare in the United States or
financial services and the asia-pacific
Reed
and that's what we've seen regulatory
authorities expect that you conduct that
due diligence so look at some of these
areas they expect you to know the
answers to these questions before you
adopt cloud for example what are the
security capabilities of the cloud
provider obviously you're going to be
seeing a lot of presentations this week
about our capabilities from a security
perspective but you need to be answered
to be able to answer these questions who
owns the data when you upload your data
to Google cloud our position is that any
data you upload into the cloud remains
yours it's your data but again
regulators expect you to know that
answer how is data being used Google
clouds position is that any data that
you provide to us will only be processed
according to your instructions to
provide the services and to protect that
data and the reason why how the data is
being used is so important is because
there are many sectors particularly
education or privacy or healthcare where
data cannot be used for any other
purpose then what is otherwise required
or prescribed by those regulators so
educational information can't be used
for any other purpose than for
educational purposes or in HIPAA for
example pH I which will talk about
health care information can't be used
for any other purpose than their provide
health healthcare services so that's
another thing regulators expect you to
ask data incident notification we'll
talk about about that a little bit later
but you know heaven forbid there's a
data incident you need to know if it's
going to happen or not because you may
have your own compliance obligations
with respect to that regulators want to
make sure you know that as well
data deletion how do you know that if
once you've deleted data from the cloud
it's actually gone regulators want you
to know we provide an obligation on
ourselves a contractual commitment to
purge the day that you've deleted so you
know that data portability what happens
if you want to take your data and move
to a different provider regulators want
to know can you take the data with you
and so you want to look into the
capabilities that we do provide for data
portability what type of data will be
stored the type of data is also very
important
with regards to whether or not it is
regulated by a regulator for example
European privacy law applies to personal
data educational records apply to
educational data of course
so not all requirements may apply to to
all the data you may be using the cloud
for so you want to look at the type of
data you're processing to determine what
regulations might apply to it of course
where is it stored we've seen regulators
ask customers to ensure they know what
data centers will be storing data or
what data centers may potentially be
storing the data and then third party
audits and certifications is anyone
verifying what we're saying is true the
one thing I should point out and I think
a lot of folks here already know this is
that there's a distinction between
Google cloud services and our consumer
services we do not serve ads on our
Google cloud products this is not a
consumer offering this is not like
Google search where you see ads based on
your search results there are no ads
there are special business-to-business
terms which I'll talk about we have
special administrator tools because our
customers are administering the service
is not Google directly and of course we
have certain enterprise services like
vault 4G suite which lets you store
offline copies of the data used for for
storage discovery purposes so we talked
about compliance assessments the things
you need to look at now let's focus on
transparency so everything that you
could be hearing this week everything
that I'm saying to you could be lies how
do you know we're not lying to you
regulators expect you to know that what
we're saying to you is true and how do
you verify that the answer is third
party audits and certifications what
that means is that we invite third party
independent auditors to come to Google
and audit our data protection practices
essentially to verify our affirmations
of what we do are true so what does that
mean from an operational perspective
let's talk about sauk to audits so for
example a third-party auditor will come
to
and assess each of our security controls
so we say that we do X we do why we do Z
the auditor comes in pursuant to a sock
to audit and they verify each one of
these controls dozens and dozens I think
hundreds of controls and the output of
that third-party auditors assessment is
a highly confidential detailed audit
report the idea then from a regulatory
compliance perspective as part of your
due diligence is to get this report and
then compare it against your own
regulatory and security and data
protection needs you compare the two you
do a delta analysis to determine if
there are any gaps and then what those
gaps are so that's for example a sock to
report I'm not going to talk about
everything but I want to highlight some
now the sock to report is as I mentioned
where auditors come in and audit us
against a certain auditing standard but
sock 2 is not a security standard and
it's not a data protection standard so
we decided to do a few years later we
did this into 13 2012 is that we adopted
ISO 27001 now ISO 27001 is an IT
security standard where the
International Organization for
Standardization creates a set of
controls they write the controls and
basically they say that if an auditor
assesses you and you've achieved these
controls then you have attained this IT
security standard so the output of that
is essentially a certification it's like
a diploma if you will so we have adopted
ISO 27001 but the thing about ISO 27001
is that it's not geared towards cloud
specifically it was drafted originally a
long time ago before cloud computing had
really taken hold so what the
International Organization for
Standardization did is that they
launched specific cloud security
controls which is ISO 27000 17 which
we've adopted as well as specific cloud
data protection and privacy controls
which is ISO 27000 18 and again the
auditors audit us against that stand
and if we attain that standard which we
have then we get a certification so as
part of your due diligence you look at
the sock to report we also have a
publicly available sock 3 and by the way
the sock 2 is NDA but it's accessible we
have a publicly available publish sock 3
and then you look at the ISO
certifications now the nice thing about
ISO is that it's an international
organization there are participants from
virtually every country in the world and
they are the ones who write the standard
themselves in other words every country
has an opportunity to create this global
standard and the reason why it's
important from a compliance perspective
is that because it's an international
standard it makes it more readily or
easily adoptable by customers across the
world and it also makes it easier for
regulatory authorities to recognize the
importance of and the validity of these
standards and certifications you'll also
see sector specific areas such as PCI
DSS which we attain for processing
payments for some of our cloud services
privacy shield which is something
related to European law which we'll talk
about in a minute FedRAMP for US
government M TCS which is a which is
helpful for financial services
particularly banks in Singapore so we'll
talk more about various frameworks this
is why certifications are so important
as a matter of fact I can think of a
story there was a an educational
institution in Northern Europe a few
years ago that were they were using G
suite for education and their regulator
sent them a letter and said how do you
know that Google is not using the
student data for serving ads daddy you
actually know is the customer so the
customer went through the ISO controls
they went through the sock - and they
found that there was a specific control
in ISO 27000 18 that were audited
against that says data will not be used
for ads without permission without
disclosure there's a limitation on how
data could be processed remember I
mentioned that earlier and they were
able to respond to the regulatory
inquiry citing the certification that we
have an ISO 27000 18
the controls that are part of that
certification and you can get the
controls directly from ISO by the way
and this is an example of some of the
control of some of the objectives and
some of the controls that are reviewed
as part of this audits I'm not going to
go through every one we don't have
enough time but you know some examples
information security purpose and scope
of processing remember I talked about
how regulators want to make sure that
processing is limited this is where that
would be covered data minimization
collection limitations not collecting or
Mort using more data than as otherwise
required to provide the services
communications security business
continuity cryptography access controls
a lot of very important interesting
areas that you might want to take a look
at in addition to again as I mentioned
the due diligence that regulators expect
you can to conduct there are also online
resources that are available we create
white papers periodically to help you in
your assessment of our services I'm
talking to talk about it and a little
while but we have recently launched a
gdpr Resource Center that helps you
assess our services with respect to the
European general data protection
regulation we have white papers
information about our data centers
security and compliance encryption this
is great because you have an opportunity
to review these and then when your
regulative regulator asks have you done
your due diligence you can say I've
looked at these white papers I've looked
at this collateral I've looked at the
sock to report I've looked at the ISO
certification I obtained the controls
from ISO and have reviewed those
compared them against our requirements
and there's a lineup and they match
another interesting aspect is data
centers regulators have often asked do
you know where the data is being stored
yeah some regulatory frameworks
specifically have required require you
to know where data is located and some
of our services actually within google
cloud allow you to locate data and
specific areas a copy of data and
specific areas but they may ask for
example why has Google chosen to put
data centers in particular regions so
let's talk about that for a minute
we choose to place data centers in
certain regions as people might imagine
for bandwidth reasons for cost for
energy savings but then of course there
are policy and rule of law
considerations we won't build a data
center in any location where there is
not a rule of law where there's no
stable government we want to make sure
that there are protections against
content copyright or trademark concerns
for provider and we can only build data
centers and we'll only build data
centers where we are allowed to do so as
a us-based company you won't see data
centers and OFAC restricted countries
for example so we've talked about the
importance of conducting compliance
assessments for your for your sector
with your council your compliance
professionals the importance of
transparency making sure you conduct
your due diligence and the information
we can provide to you to help with that
now let's talk about contracts now third
party audits are terrific they verify
what we're saying is true but it doesn't
mean anything unless it's put in writing
and we have seen situations where
financial regulators have asked our
customers for copies of their cloud
contracts with their cloud provider to
verify that that they reflect the
regulatory needs of that particular
industry we've seen financial services
regulators do this more than once so
let's do a brief let's have a brief
overview of what we provide from a
contractual perspective because again
these obligations need to be in writing
so first we have the customer agreement
this includes commercial terms billing
and payments how much it's going to cost
whether there's going to be what type of
Texas technical support there's going to
be who owns the intellectual property as
I mentioned you own the data that you
upload into Google Cloud those covered
the general commercial terms but then we
also have something and I'm going to
focus on this in the next slide
particularly we have something called
data processing terms this is a special
part of the contract that sets forth the
data protection obligations that we have
with respect to the protection of our
Google cloud customers data
this is something that we actually did
not have originally we had this
incorporated into our earlier contracts
but having a special section a special
amendment for data protection is
something that we implemented in 2012
based actually on guidance from data
protection regulators in Europe this
includes things like the privacy
commitments remember that data use
restriction we won't use your data for
ads or for any other purpose and per
your instruction or provide the services
that's where it is it's in the data
processing amendment a commitment to
maintain third party audits right we
want to keep doing this and for be able
to provide you with these certifications
an obligation to delete the data for
example I'll go into more detail of the
data processing terms in the next slide
as I mentioned but also a cloud contract
isn't necessarily appropriate for every
country for every vertical so for
certain verticals for certain countries
for certain areas we have special
industry specific term special
amendments that would be appropriate for
that particular region for example
financial services regulatory authority
have special requirements and expect
their banks their securities firms to be
able to have terms that address those
requirements business associates
agreements which is important for HIPAA
that is u.s. us-based protection of
patient records as I mentioned financial
services terms GU model clauses which is
used to X or transfer personal data from
Europe to the rest of the world and
FedRAMP which is for US government data
so let's talk about the data processing
terms which I mentioned earlier they are
the data protection obligations that we
provide and from a regulatory compliance
perspective this is something that's
going to be particularly important when
it comes to working with regulatory
authorities it is essentially the
privacy policy for google cloud
contracts and it was something that as I
mentioned we initially launched in 2012
but it's been evolving over the years
it's not a static document we are
continually getting feedback from
regulatory authorities particularly in
Europe and in regulated markets like
financial services and then we're
updating it over the year
to reflect latest requirements as a
matter of fact it was most recently
updated for GDP our that we did this in
2017 to be ready for when GDP art takes
it or took effect in may 2018 and
incidentally if you are existing Google
Cloud customers you want to make sure
that you opt in and use the latest data
processing terms for GDP are well let's
talk about some of the areas within
within GDP are or specifically within
the data processing terms excuse me this
is where we include the limitation on
processing as I mentioned before we
won't use the data for any other purpose
and to provide the services there are no
ads I'm data deletion this is where we
include the obligation that when you
delete data it will be purged within a
specific period of time it's not going
to just sit there forever and I would I
would venture that this is better than
what a lot of people do on Prem this is
where we include the obligation to
maintain these third party audits and
certifications because after all what's
the point if as soon as you sign up we
no longer do it so this is why here we
include an obligation to constantly and
continually do it throughout the entire
term of your contract some processors we
haven't talked about this before what if
Google uses vendors or third parties the
regulatory authorities that you work
with will want to know is Google using
any vendors are they sharing data with
anyone well from a Google perspective we
do the vast majority of processing
ourselves of course because we're Google
but we do have some vendors and so here
we include an obligation to make sure
that we let you know who those vendors
are we provide you with notice in case
we decide to use a new vendor that they
comply with certain very stringent
security requirements and the vendors we
use even though we do the vast majority
of processing generally would be things
like technical support providing 24/7
customer service that 24-hour access
different language support so they are
there and this is where you can find
them an obligation to protect your data
of the security measures that we'll use
remember I told you about data incident
notification that's something else
that's critical
I hope it never happens but let's say
that there is a data incident that
affects your data there's a breach for
example many regulatory authorities
demand that you have obligations to your
own customers to your own users if there
is a breach but how can you fulfill that
obligation if your cloud provider
doesn't tell you if it happens to them
so we include an obligation and we've
actually been doing this for many years
probably from the first days of Google
Cloud G suite where we provide you with
notification if there's an incident that
affects your data and of course the
other thing is that we make available a
data privacy officer that folks can
contact if they have any questions that
affect European privacy for example so
that's why data processing terms are so
important so we've talked about
compliance assessments we've talked
about transparency contracts and now
let's talk a little bit about regulatory
frameworks I want to touch upon finance
because financial services is a very big
deal there's been a huge adoption by
banks of cloud services so let's talk a
little bit about what regulators in the
financial services space have been
asking questions about in our experience
so as I mentioned all the areas we
discussed regarding the due diligence
questions at the beginning you know who
owns the data where as it's stored per
processing limitations but then
regulators in the financial services
space also maintain very strict
oversight over their banks obviously
it's a highly highly regulated industry
so regulatory authorities want to make
sure that when a financial services
customer moves all of their data into
the cloud that the regulator still
maintains the ability to exercise
oversight over that data financial
services regulators expect that a bank
will be able to subject themselves to an
audit by the regulatory authority that
the regulator's choosing and they want
to make sure that if the cloud customer
moves our data to the cloud they can do
so so when our financial services terms
we include language that says we
acknowledge you customer as the bank are
regulated by the
Latorre Authority and that and that you
will as such pursuant to your
obligations make that data available to
the regulator if they request an audit
from you and that they still have
jurisdiction regulators want to see that
type of language so with the customer so
that customers can verify to the
regulator's that they can still be
subjected to audits for example but it
goes beyond that some regulatory
authorities in the financial services
space want to be able to regulate us or
audit us directly as the provider so
we've had to address that and agree to
these sort of requirements for certain
jurisdictions same thing with customers
in many different markets customers are
expected to be able to conduct audits
directly over Google and we agree to
this in many jurisdictions now naturally
we much prefer the use of third-party
audit reports and certifications because
it's much much more scalable but in
situations where that is an issue we
still agree to it because that's what
many Financial Services regulators have
expected of us another area that we
address so that's financial services
another area that that we look at and we
provide services for would be healthcare
in the US for example the Health
Insurance Portability and Accountability
Act you've heard me mention HIPPA we do
provide services to entities that are
regulated by HIPAA that are covered by
HIPAA HIPAA involves protection of
protected health information and to
address this for example we offer what's
called business associates agreements
remember when I was talking about
contracts where we had three different
slides we talked about the main
commercial contract the data processing
terms and sector specific terms the
business associates agreement would be a
great example of sector specific terms
we also have special implementation
guides like the HIPAA implementation
guide where you can review it and
determine how best to deploy Google
cloud services when it comes to
protection of data this is again white
paper resources that I mentioned earlier
in providing services to the educational
market FERPA for example is data that
involves student records that must be
protected so we have special language
that addresses that in the education
space
and then there are other markets like
government for example in the US as I
mentioned you heard me mention FedRAMP
often the FedRAMP operation
authorization to operate where it we're
at moderate level and that means
government agency certain government
agencies can store their data in Google
Cloud United Kingdom the NCSC and the
participation and the G cloud
marketplace to help government entities
in the United Kingdom use Google cloud
and again you mentioned you heard me
mention that ISO certification is
helpful globally in the vast majority of
markets in many cases a lot of these
programs are related to ISO and we can
expect that in some governments they are
of special requirements such as FedRAMP
just an example of some of the financial
services companies that have adopted
Google cloud over the years again these
are highly regulated yet we have been
able to create an offering which helps
the customers address their regulatory
compliance needs in the cloud so we've
been very successful in being able to do
this it's a lot of work but again this
is a developing area and very exciting
now I can't talk about regulatory
frameworks without talking about
European privacy so let's talk a little
bit about that now this involves the
protection of personal data of European
of European citizens European users so
let's start from the at least from the
beginning of my discussion this really
started as far as we're involved with
the European Data Protection Directive
of 1995 this implemented very strict
privacy controls over personal data of
Europeans and this basically set the
stage for what Google cloud and a lot of
our club provider peers would focus on
when creating our services particularly
when it comes to business to business
services one very important restriction
of the EU data protection directive of
1995 was that it limited the export or
the transfer of personal data from
Europe to any other country in the world
that was not considered to have adequate
privacy
protections as determined by Europe now
to help address this data transfer issue
you have to remember when the Data
Protection Directive was passed the
internet wasn't really being used for
commerce alright there's a huge shift so
safe-harbor was passed in 2000 that
would allow the transfer of personal
data to the US how many people know now
that safe harbor was invalidated here we
go so and then in 2012 because many
countries were concerned that they
couldn't receive personal data the
European Commission launched model
clauses and what that is is these are
special contractual terms where if you
enter into these with your cloud
provider data could be transferred
anywhere in the world assuming that both
the customer and the cloud provider
comply with their requirements and then
later in 2016 the EU and the u.s.
created privacy shield which is that
again another framework that replaces
safe harbor to allow the transfer of
personal data to the United States so
the net-net of this is that even though
the European privacy legislation limits
the transfer of personal data from
Europe there are regulatory frameworks
that Google has adopted privacy shield
and model clauses that allow data to
flow through our global infrastructure
of data centers now let's turn to what's
most important to a lot of people the
recently passed general data protected
the recently enacted general data
protection regulation gdpr
which replaces the 1995 directive the
gdpr of course is extremely significant
it's the most important piece of
legislation since the 1995 directive and
the idea is that it's a regulation it's
not a directive what's the difference
the directive from 1995 basically
directed member states in Europe to pass
their own laws that reflected the
requirements of the directive the result
was similar laws but somewhat of a
patchwork which made compliance
challenging for providers and customers
alike so this is a regulation it has
direct force of effective law presumably
to help reduce the likelihood of
in consistent enforcement or
inconsistent laws and it strengthens the
rights of individuals so what does that
mean as far as what the general data
protection regulation requires you'll
see a lot of things here looks look
familiar to what we've talked about
before so the core principles of
processing remain the same as what the
Data Protection Directive had purposeful
limitation data will only be used and
processed based on instructions from
customers and for a particular purpose
commitments on data deletion so when
data is deleted it's actually deleted
security commitments international data
transfers you remember you heard me talk
about privacy shield and model clauses
is very important to allow the flow of
data around the world those dratted data
transfer mechanisms are still recognized
and valid under gdpr it's very important
there are stricter obligations for data
processors I should mention that
customers under the European model are
typically data controllers they decide
how the data is processed and Google
Cloud as the cloud provider is the data
processor we follow the instructions of
our customers only when it comes to the
processing of data so there are new
stricter obligations in gdpr than there
were in the Data Protection Directive
and this is based on actually and a lot
of guidance the data protection
regulators have issued over the years
that guidance was in turn incorporated
into gdpr
but we've been doing it for many years
so it's not new for us
you remember incident notification where
he indicated that we provide a
commitment to let you know if there's a
data incident that's now part of gdpr
we've been doing it for many many years
but it's now a requirement data return
there's an hour requirement and gdpr
that there is a data portability
capability which as I mentioned to you
we have as part of our services and in
our contracts there is an obligation
that data protection regulators and
customers have an audit right which
we've also maintained for many many
years now and brand-new aspects there
are greater fines you've probably heard
a lot about GDP are in the news because
the fines for non-compliance
can be significant very very high also
gdpr applies directly to providers like
Google it's not just the customer that's
responsible for compliance but now under
GDP are the providers are responsible
for compliance as well records are
processing you have to maintain
information about yourself and who is
actually processing the data and who is
responsible and detailed contractual
provisions that address GDP are
requirements you remember I mentioned
earlier that we want to make sure that
you if you have already opted into using
Google Cloud that you update your data
processing terms to reflect GDP our
commitments this is one of the reasons
you want to make sure that the terms you
have are compliant we have that
available online you can do a Google
search and opt in if you need to as far
as where customers should start of
course you should familiarize yourself
with GDP are you should seek counsel
yourself we are not your lawyers this is
not legal advice
no the type of data that you're
collecting as the customer you're a data
controller so you want to make sure that
you know what you're collecting while
you're collecting it from your employees
or your customers the reasons you're
collecting it making sure you don't
retain it for longer than you have to
you want to review your current controls
and any gaps you want to make sure that
you leverage the data protection
features of google cloud you remember I
mentioned that we talked about our
security controls and our saw to report
the white papers what's available
publicly online leverage that for gdpr
compliance and of course gdpr is
evolving the law has passed but data
protection authority guidance continues
and so you want to make sure you monitor
any updates to what this may bring in
the future as regulators issue ongoing
advice and finally we have a gdpr
resource center that is also very
important when it comes to ensuring that
you have conducted your due diligence
when adopting Google clouds we talk
about contracts and terms compliance
compliance analysis and and relevant
products and services that you can
leverage to help with your gdpr
compliance
so that's very important the other thing
I mentioned was regulatory engagement
it's important to stay step ahead so
from our perspective as a cloud provider
we work very closely with data
protection authorities financial
services regulators around the world to
ensure that the services that we are
providing to help ensure the services we
are providing are consistent with
regulatory requirements worldwide that
may involve educating regulatory
authorities about the cloud but also
monitoring whether or not they are
issuing guidance regarding cloud
services adoption and also being able to
take feedback from the regulatory
authority folks and then incorporate
that into our products and services like
I mentioned at the beginning of our
program so let's summarize we talked
about the importance of conducting a
compliance assessment in your particular
field in your vertical we talked about
the questions regulators expect you to
ask we talked about transparency the
importance of making sure you have the
information you need so that you can
conduct a meaningful risk assessment to
address what regulators want you to do
contracts the importance of making sure
you have things in writing and have this
so you can demonstrate to regulators you
have the provisions you need and finally
we talked about regulatory frameworks
and the latest trends we've seen
including financial services health care
and GE PR so ultimately we'd like you to
partner with us to meet your data
protection and compliance needs we hope
this presentation has been helpful for
you thank you very much folks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]